this is really something else um
as as we've been covering joe biden has
been doing a lot
as president-elect donald trump as
president hasn't been doing a damn thing
for months now
many of his allies have abandoned him
west palm beach doesn't seem to want him
down there new york city certainly
doesn't want him or his kids
it's just sort of a sad danumand for
donald trump
but trump has found some unwavering
support
in some elements of right-wing media
including oan newsmax
and still in some places on fox news the
the more sycophantic ones anyway
so later we're going to do a deep dive
into a particular fox news interview
that went comically haywire
but i want to give you a sampling of the
clips that donald trump has been
retweeting and amplifying and the
takeaway here for me
is that the next four years are going to
be insane that's that's my takeaway
we'll see if you come away with the same
notion fox news was nuts during barack
obama's presidency
but fox news competing with oan and
newsmax for the same audience is likely
to lead
to a sort of one-upmanship contest for
who can come up
with the most wacky anti-biden
conspiracy theories and false reports so
let's dive right in
in the first clip retweeted by donald
trump there was a panel on the show the
five
about trump being admired in 2020 and
one of the five people figures out a way
to delusionally brown-nose donald trump
trump loved it and retweeted it take a
look
well see i think president trump stands
at the top because he has been
an incredible president he has though
marie he is someone who led
one of the strongest economies we saw
pre-kovet this is a man who has gotten
more middle east peace deals done
uh in just one term alone he's gotten
more than half of the
all the peace deals we have seen uh in
our nation's history done
done in one term this is someone who got
mexico to step up to the plate on things
like illegal immigration this is someone
who's brought a business approach
to washington dc therefore solving
problems
when people like joe biden who have been
there forever created the mess that
president trump went to go
fix and i also think it's remarkable
because you have a media
who has vilified him demonized him lied
about him and yet he still sits
atop the throne and marie i love you but
this must be a hard segment to leave
so just to pick one thing because
there's so much nonsense here
she said half of all peace deals in the
nation's history
were done by donald trump during his
first term okay
that didn't ring true to me so i decided
i would fact check it
now some of these so-called deals trump
got done
were not even really peace deals and
i'll explain that in a moment
but if you go back to the treaty of
tripoli in 1805 there are 11 of what we
would call
overtly peace deals and then there are
way more that aren't called peace deals
but effectively are peace deals to some
degree
she says trump did more peace deals in
one term than were previously done in
all of american history
that is very much false but the real
issue is that the deals trump did are
really mirages
trump did a deal with the uae and israel
those countries had already agreed to
engage independent of trump and they
weren't in what we would call a conflict
to begin with
bahrain and israel same thing and then
of course trump's promise on
israeli-palestinian peace with jared
kushner was going to figure out for us
silence no progress at all another clip
these are clips retweeted by trump
sucking up to him this is from oan
a totally made-up story fabricated out
of thin air
about military ballot tampering trump
loves it he retweeted it
well new investigations reveal military
ballots were
major targets of democrat voter fraud in
november
reports on thursday note thousands of
military ballots were potentially
tampered with at polling stations during
the general election
this after several witnesses came
forward during a hearing in georgia
wednesday
with both photo and video evidence
of rampant fraud republican poll
watchers also claimed they got locked
out of the counting stations when it
came to look
time to look over military ballots which
typically
lean red so that's absolutely nuts not a
single court has found
any merit to any of the claims you just
heard trump doesn't care
he loves it he retweets it next clip
also from oan
which presents a battle for the white
house battle
the election's over biden won trump lost
doesn't matter trump loves it this one
is made even funnier because the anchor
is struggling to deliver the scripted
agit trash like
she's she's struggling to even read this
nonsense off of the prompter
the battle continues for the white house
as president trump and his legal team
continue to reveal and investigate
the irregularities of the 2020 election
president trump has several avenues to
secure his second term
primarily the state legislatures have
the constitutional authority and
responsibility
to select the correct electors for their
respective states
seven states had both sets of electors
vote on december 14th
pennsylvania georgia michigan wisconsin
arizona nevada and new mexico
all had republican electors cast their
votes as well as the democrat electors
currently all seven of the state
secretaries of state have sent the
democrat electors to be counted
the state legislatures have the
constitutional responsibility
to ensure that the electors sent from
their state are correct
so that's a complete fantasy none of
that is going on
and then one more here may be the
nuttiest one an oan reporter
named pearson sharp stands in front of a
blackboard reminiscent of glenn beck's
old conspiracy show
bunch of stuff written in chalk
outlining a completely
farcical understanding of how elections
work
this is a five-minute clip i'm not going
to torture you like that
i'll just play 40 seconds for you to
give you a sense of it
the so-called election results on
november 3rd
are puzzling to a lot of people at least
75 million but probably
a lot more that's because up until that
point
all signs were that president trump was
set to win a historic
victory over joe biden and many still
believe that's exactly what happened
even if the alleged vote counts tell a
different story
despite what the mainstream media has
declared president trump
was projected to win because he had
ushered in
an unprecedented era of prosperity for
americans
from all walks of life at the start of
2020 before
the chinese pandemic and democratic
governors devastated
our nation american optimism about the
economy was at an all-time high
that guy has never seen a point he will
actually make
just droning on and on with
circumstantial
uh conjecture but his point is
trump won and trump liked it so trump
retweeted that video
these are the things where if you even
see a reputable reporter retweet this
you say
wow that's a concern the president of
the united states
is retweeting this stuff we'll have more
coverage of this
on our instagram page make sure you're
following us there
at david pakman show and follow me on
instagram for pictures from my vacation
warning they are very boring uh i'm
david
pakman on instagram